Unexpected cameos, and a major
character transformation.
The Savage She-Hulk was finally
brought to life on screen.
In the season finale of "She-Hulk: Attorney
at Law," Tatiana Maslany's Jennifer Walters,
also known as She-Hulk, faced
several surprises. First off,
her creepy one-time date Todd ended up being the
HulkKing and the mastermind behind Intelligencia,
and he was able to cunningly get his hands on a
sample of Walters' blood. We also discovered that
Emil Blonsky, played by Tim Roth, is still
turning into Abomination, telling Walters,
"Yeah, I do speaking engagements.
Nothing bad, strictly for profit."
And to top it all off, after being MIA
for most of the season, Mark Ruffalo's
Bruce Banner literally dropped in to save
the day. But as this is She-Hulk's show,
Walters steps in and decides that this is
not the finale she wants. After realizing
the writers are not the ones in control, she
fights her way to the "Knowledge Enhanced
Visual Interconnectivity Nexus" to plead her
case for the ending her character deserves.
But before we get to the chaos of "She-Hulk's"
last episode, we're first treated to an entirely
new, retro opening credit scene. Complete with
voiceover narration and late 70s-early 80s style
graphics, it's reminiscent of the original "The
Incredible Hulk" series opener. But unlike the
cheerful, playful, and beautiful She-Hulk
we're used to seeing, we get a much bigger,
angrier, and more aggressive She-Hulk who looks an
awful lot like she could be Lou Ferrigno's twin.
"Don't make me angry. You
wouldn't like me when I'm angry."
As the opening finishes, the title card reads,
"The Savage She-Hulk." For those who don't know,
the Savage She-Hulk moniker has a much longer
and deeper history in the Marvel Comics world,
beginning with the very first "She-Hulk"
issue, and coming back to the forefront
in the "Avengers" comic series that started in
2018. She-Hulk wasn't always the level-headed,
intelligent Hulk that Tatiana Maslany
portrays her to be in the MCU's "She-Hulk:
Attorney at Law." When Stan Lee and John
Buscema first introduced She-Hulk in 1980,
it was as "The Savage She-Hulk." In fact,
Jen Walters's origin story was pretty
different from the version introduced
in the Disney+ series. In the comics,
Walters was shot by the henchmen of a mobster she
had a case against, and Bruce Banner, who had just
come back into his cousin's life, performed
an emergency blood transfusion to save her.
While recovering in the hospital, Walters
starts to notice that she feels different
but assumes it's the result of the medications
the doctors and nurses gave her. But when the
gunmen come to the hospital again to try
and silence her, Jen's rage transforms her
into what became known as the Savage She-Hulk.
This title lasted for 25 issues, with the first
mention coming from a nurse who unknowingly tells
Walters, "That female savage was just horrible!"
Fans of both Marvel Comics and the MCU know that
Banner's Hulk has always been different. The
Hulk generally has a separate personality from
Banner and is consumed with causing destruction
and shares no consciousness with him, although
Ruffalo's Professor Hulk appears to reconcile
both. Despite the comics' title, "Savage
She-Hulk," Walters and her Hulk were always
the same person, sharing the same consciousness.
Even so, Walters still thinks of herself as more
of a beast now, referring to herself as "The
Savage She-Hulk" in "Savage She-Hulk #2."
During Jason Aaron's run writing
the "Avengers" comics in 2018,
he tried to make She-Hulk more like the
Hulk, but it didn't go over so well with
fans. In a particularly unfavorable Reddit
thread about the comics, one user wrote,
"[Aaron] derailed She-Hulk and keeps
doubling and tripling down on it."
Unsurprisingly, the character
eventually reverted back to
the form fans seem to prefer in "Avengers #50."